[Aplausos]
bueno todos ustedes habrán vivido viven
o vivirán una situación inesperada a lo
largo de sus vidas y si no son ustedes
serán sus familias
cuando parece que todo va bien que todo
marcha de repente aparece la enfermedad
y da igual quién seas lo que tengas o
como seas porque ponerse enfermo no hace
distinciones a veces la enfermedad es
especialmente cruel en su manera de
decirte hola aquí estoy y vengo a
cambiarte la vida y entonces sabrán
exactamente de qué estoy hablando porque
lo que significa ingresar en una unidad
de cuidados intensivos solo lo pueden
entender aquellas personas que han
pasado por ello de una u otra manera
podrá ser por un accidente de tráfico o
por una infección grave por un infarto
de corazón o porque tengan que operar la
verdad es que hay manera es
prácticamente infinita de perder la
salud y de repente estarás solo en una
habitación tumbado boca arriba 8 metros
cuadrados mirando al techo y rodeado de
máquinas como si estuvieras en una nave
espacial
tendrá sus ondas por todos los orificios
del cuerpo
máquinas que sustituyen la función de
sus órganos y les mantienen conectado a
la vida y un montón de monitores que
pitan insistentemente y nos dicen cómo
se encuentran latido a latido y me estoy
refiriendo exactamente a esto
bueno soy gabriel eras médico
especialista en cuidados intensivos del
año 2007 las unidades de cuidados
intensivos son ese lugar del hospital
donde trabajamos a toda velocidad donde
sentimos la prisa la velocidad y los
cambios de ritmo
hay una mezcla de tensión en el ambiente
que muchas veces se rompe por ese sonido
del sonido de las máquinas y por los
llantos o los gritos de las familias
trabajamos a máxima velocidad aplicando
nuestros conocimientos técnicos y
nuestras habilidades físicas con un solo
objetivo lo que todos ustedes nos pidan
a nosotros es que salvemos vidas
[Música]
como hizo un compañero australiano peter
soul nosotros nos salvamos vidas en el
sentido estricto de la palabra si acaso
las prolongamos nosotros trabajamos en
un sitio como si fuéramos en
practicamente equilibristas subidos al
alambre que va entre la vida y la muerte
y trabajamos sin red
cómo pueden entender esto es un trabajo
super cansado porque ríes y lloras
sufres y te involucras y cada día te
llevas el trabajo a casa
de forma objetiva nosotros hacemos muy
bien nuestro trabajo de tal manera que
la sociedad española medicina intensiva
ha comunicado cifras de supervivencia en
torno al 90 por ciento en las uci de
españa es decir la uci da vida
no es lo mismo ingresar en españa que en
otras partes del mundo donde las tasas
de mortalidad oscilan entre el 15 y el
30 por ciento hace 15 años ya
recibí una beca de la agencias para la
cooperación internacional y estudio y
viendo en bolivia y allí fue la primera
vez que yo quise una unidad de cuidados
intensivos me impactó tanto que supe que
sería intensivista pero hay una cosa que
me impactó aún más todavía que es ver
como la falta de recursos económicos y
tecnológicos hace que la gente fallezca
y esto lo vemos todos los días por
televisión todos nosotros pero es lo
mismo verlo por televisión que vivirlo
en persona porque en un sistema no
subvencionado por el gobierno cuando un
paciente en el sava la uci se le acababa
el dinero se le daba de alta a la planta
y fallecía
y esto mismo lo puede haber cuatro años
después en ghana en áfrica ambas
sociedades tenían absolutamente
interiorizado el hecho de morir igual
que vivían y tenían totalmente
naturalizado este hecho
en ambos sitios también ha aprendido una
cosa que es que la falta de medios se
suple muchas veces con exceso de
imaginación
durante mis años de ejercicio de la
profesión he podido ver cómo
ha evolucionado la sanidad de forma
espectacular y como antes patologías que
eran sentencias de muerte ahora ahora se
resuelven con éxito
pero hay una cosa que bajo mi punto de
vista ha permanecido prácticamente
oculta a los sentidos y eso es el
cuidado de lo invisible y de eso les
vengo a hablar de lo subjetivo de lo
emocional de lo intangible está puesto
de moda eso de la medicina centrada en
el paciente y palabras como co-creación
empoderamiento pero yo creo que está
incompleto porque el cuidado lo
invisible afecta a las tres partes que
formamos el sistema a los pacientes a
las familias ya los profesionales
por qué
qué pasa con las heridas emocionales de
nuestros pacientes que les pasa cuando
se van de alta de la uci con secuelas
qué pasa con la angustia de las familias
y qué pasa que nosotros los
profesionales nos sufrimos
el cuidado lo invisible implica entender
que los cuerpos duelen pero las personas
sufrimos el dolor físico se controla
fácilmente con analgésicos pero el dolor
emocional el sufrimiento hay que
prestarle la atención que merece y se lo
voy a intentar explicar con varios
ejemplos
imaginen por un momento
imagina
qué estás tumbado en una superficie dura
que tu cuerpo ya sin arte sobre el suelo
porque ha sido víctima de un atropello y
de un accidente de tráfico
tengo de todo el cuerpo no saber dónde
estás no sabes qué ha pasado
pero estás vivo
intentas abrir los ojos y reconocer a la
gente de su alrededor pero no puedes y
los vuelves a cerrar y te sumas de su
mes en el silencio más absoluto
sigues vivo y de repente abre los ojos y
está rodeado por un montón de personas
que no conoces y empiezas a notar cosas
raras cosas como que te molesta algo en
la garganta y es que necesitas un
aparato que respire por ti y empieza a
ver todas tus limitaciones no puedes
hablar quieres gritar no puedes quieres
llevar no puedes quieres comer no puedes
quieres que llamen a tu familia no
puedes decirlo no te puedes mover
pero hay una cosa que sí que puedes
hacer
qué es oír hoy es todo lo que pasa a tu
alrededor
hoy es como vienen los profesionales se
ponen delante de ti y hablan de ti como
si tú no estuvieras delante como si
fueses un trozo de carne aunque ellos no
se dan cuenta
hoy es como hablan de ti como si fueras
una enfermedad como si fueras una
patología y desde luego como no la
conoces porque no has estudiado medicina
no sabe de qué va pero no te suena nada
bien
y sobre todo
hoy es las alarmas y cada vez que suena
una alarma piensas que es el final y te
vas a morir
en ese momento el dolor se junta con el
miedo un miedo atroz un miedo de lado
que te perfora por dentro y que encima
no puedes compartir porque no puedes
hablar y estás solo
tienes los mejores medios estás en el
mejor hospital tienes la mejor
tecnología a tu alcance y no es
suficiente y esto mismo por lo que le
pasó hace 20 años a katie katie torpe en
nueva zelanda en su más absoluta soledad
algo le pasó
o no
[Música]
en life support
no
en esto
i
d
es decir cuando uno está absolutamente
desesperado lo único que necesita es
otra persona
no necesita la mejor tecnología o las
mejores máquinas
si eres el familiar estarás al otro lado
de la puerta es un lugar que puedes
reconocer fácilmente porque pone no
pasar y estarás en una sala muy grande
rodeado de un montón de personas cada
uno con su dolor cada uno con su
angustia cada uno con su sufrimiento en
estado estático prácticamente atado de
manos y pies rumiando y digo rumiando y
no digo otra cosa porque muchas veces
las familias son tratadas como si fuesen
ganados esperando que abran la puerta
para entrar corriendo a ver a sus
familias y esto no lo digo como crítica
al sistema lo digo como un hecho
objetivo que por otro lado nadie sea
para pensar si esto nos va bien
hay unidades de cuidados intensivos
donde las visitas son media hora al día
y esto significa que la familia está
pendiente del teléfono 24 horas sin
dormir igual a lo mejor te llaman a las
4 a la mañana para decirte que algo no
ha ido bien
qué pasa con ese sufrimiento qué pasa
con esa angustia qué pasa con la
cantidad de preguntas que se quedan sin
hacer
la familia permanece como es hecho antes
atada de manos y pies cuando realmente
lo que necesitaría es estar acompañar
ayudar sentirse útiles y sentir también
que hay esperanza y si no hay esperanza
sentir que sus familiares enfermos no
van a tener dolor ni van a sufrir pero
con trabajo personal a ver si puedo
mi padre falleció hace tres meses
víctima
de una lucha contra el cáncer de más de
20 años
hace tres años tuve la conversación más
dura de mi vida en la que como médico
intentaba explicarle que no había mucho
más que hacer
pero claro no era un paciente cualquiera
para mí llevaba diez años dando
información a familiares de pacientes en
situación crítica y era la primera vez
que estaba sentado al otro lado de la
mesa y como dijo sentía el dolor de
saber y la rabia de saber qué bueno pues
que la enfermedad ganaba y que había que
aceptarlo entonces fue mi padre el que
dijo bueno chicos pues hasta aquí hemos
llegado
he vivido bien todos estos años
vamos a dejarlo estar
yo no sabía que en aquel momento me
estaba haciendo un regalo porque hace
tres meses vivimos
el dolor de su fallecimiento en familia
acompañándolo y respetando su voluntad
de no ser conectado a aparatos y
máquinas
y el regalo que me estaba haciendo era
que viviéramos sobre el dolor y no
eliminamos el dolor y la angustia de no
saber cuál eran sus deseos
cómo pueden entender
a los profesionales de la sanidad nos
encanta nuestro trabajo porque si no no
hay quien lo aguante
[Aplausos]
se publicó en eeuu no hace mucho tiempo
una encuesta que decía que el 45 por
ciento de los médicos
no volvería a elegir su profesión en
caso de poder robo binario y dar marcha
atrás y decía que claro que si los
sueldos las cargas de trabajo y sobre
todo la pérdida de expectativas que no
se cumplieron es decir lo que yo pensaba
que iba a ser esto no es lo que era
nosotros todos los días nos pide lo
mejor y se lo damos a todos
llega un momento
en que bueno
ustedes realmente no se dan cuenta pero
ponen las otras expectativas que muchas
veces no son ciertas
porque ya le dije al principio de la
charla que nosotros nos salvamos vidas
en algún momento entre ustedes y
nosotros y sobre todo a los médicos
estoy hablando nos hicieron creer que
éramos algo así como dioses y les
garantizo que no hay nada más lejos de
la realidad
y desde aquí en este punto rojo
reivindicó el derecho de sentirnos
vulnerables porque así sentiremos el
sufrimiento y nos podremos acercar a su
sufrimiento diagnosticarlo y tratarlo de
forma precoz
acaso no sufrimos los profesionales pues
hay un momento que sufrimos de lo lindo
que es justo en el momento la
información de más noticias
hace unos años ingresó una mujer de 30
años embarazada al final de su embarazo
en una unidad de cuidados intensivos
para porque tenía alteración de la
coagulación de la sangre y la tensión
alta en principio iba todo bien primer
embarazo 40 semanas todo felicidad pero
de repente la paciente empezó a sangrar
ella sentía que se le iba la vida y
gritaba pidiendo ayuda
a llevar un corrido a quirófano y a
pesar de transfundir la toda la sangre
que había en el hospital y hacer todo lo
técnicamente científicamente posible
la paciente falleció
y el niño falleció
ahí empieza la tortura del profesional
que dice de marjah cómo es posible que
pasen estas cosas
que se me ha escapado
y cuando estás ahí en esa tortura tienes
que bajar al infierno que ese sí que es
el infierno
y salir a informar al marido
y ahí pasan tres cosas y les digo
primero no queremos estar en esa
situación nadie quiere estar nadie
querría estar en esta situación
segundo
no estamos preparados suficientemente
para ello y tercero eso deja huella para
siempre
como pueden ver por todas las alegrías
que estoy contando
el sufrimiento es una cosa absolutamente
subjetiva es universal pero es de
interés general y entonces yo dándole
vueltas a la cabeza digo vale ya está
que hacemos bueno
tenemos que recuperar entre todos
el poder de los sentidos que la
objetividad científica y la velocidad en
el trabajo ha hecho que dejemos a un
lado
tenemos que volver a mirar
a escuchar lo que se dice y lo que no se
dice
a oler y a palpar las necesidades de
nuestros pacientes de las familias y de
los profesionales y entre todos ustedes
y nosotros tenemos que hacer la
revolución de la emoción tenemos que
hacer un movimiento social y una labor
educativa que ponga en valor el cuidado
de lo invisible no se trata de salvar
vidas o del éxito del fracaso se trata
de luchar por conseguir pasar de una
sanidad ejemplar a una sanidad excelente
y centrada en las personas donde las
emociones de todos nosotros no estén
metidas en un armario
desde febrero de 2014 un grupo de
personas nos pusimos a trabajar para
personas y nos pusimos a hacer visible
lo invisible y lo llamamos a este
movimiento lo llamamos proyecto busti
escrito con h de humano que casualmente
es la letra muda
y empezamos a pensar ya buscar cómo
sería de sauce amable es agustín
excelente
y sería mejorando la comunicación entre
todos nosotros abriendo las puertas y
dejando que las familias se impliquen y
ayuden en el cuidado de sus familiares
re motivando a los profesionales
mejorando los espacios y haciéndolos más
amables y más cómodos
tendríamos que recuperar la biografía de
los pacientes para poder seguirla
diagnosticarla y diagnosticar mejor el
sufrimiento
tendríamos que implementar lo intangible
cosas como la música porque quien no
tiene una canción que le cura
o la atención de los psicólogos dentro
de las unidades
tendríamos que formar a los
profesionales en relación de ayuda
trabajo en equipo escucha activa empatía
compasión
y por último tendríamos que naturalizar
lo inevitable darle espacio a la muerte
pensar en ella y pensar que los cuidados
al final de la biografía implican seguir
cuidando en forma intensiva pero con
otros objetivos
tenemos los mejores medios tenemos la
mejor tecnología los mejores
profesionales y solo nos falta el mejor
trato y la buena noticia amigos es que
depende de nosotros
porque juntos sumamos más y juntos
hacemos posible el cambio
mi sorpresa fue que esta idea tan simple
tan lógica y tan redonda
se fue extendiendo por toda la geografía
española
y ha ido traspasando fronteras y
resonando e incendiando el corazón de
miles de personas
porque como dice nuestro logo luego del
proyecto
nuestra arma más poderosa no se ve estoy
hablando de nuestra alma humana en
llamas muchas gracias